bunch of questions but i like throwing
some fun ones before i you know get
started into the movie um and if someone
has actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you'd like them to watch
and why
wow what a question steve um
maybe i'd like to watch
my squid man in pirates
because it's one of the only films i've
ever watched myself
because i'm a squid you know what i mean
so what are you gonna say you you hate
my squid well get over it you know what
i mean don't come to me with your squid
problems
um so i and i and also because i think
it's a magnificent creature and it's not
and it looks
sort of more glamorous and more more
impressive than i do
uh and also the films are brilliant so
maybe the squid the visual effects for
that for davey jones and everything they
still stand up uh when you watch them
today they were so well done on those
films yeah the director when he first
saw the creature that finished when they
done a kind of half a scene or something
he's what he said to the guys was get
your acceptance speech ready that was
actually what he said and they did they
won an oscar
i mean incredible incredible achievement
there were about a hundred guys that you
know uh industrial like magic who made
that who contributed to that creature
and it's a it's a stunning achievement
i i 100 agree with you um did you know
at an early age that you wanted to be an
actor when did it actually was it a
performance
how did you sort of realize this is what
i want to do well when i was at grammar
school i was i went to a catholic
grammar school where
you were
largely educated by catholic priests and
there was a there was a catholic priest
called father richards we used to call
him little richards obviously and he was
the drama priest and i was tall and i
had a reasonable memory so i used to get
leading roles and i was tall and
therefore didn't have to play girls
which was a bit of a result in those
days and uh anyway he and i didn't
realize it wasn't like now where
everybody knows you can be an actor and
you can make you can have a career you
know you can make money or there was no
there was no precedent for that round
our way and nobody knew any actor you
know nobody knew about being an actor or
anything of that kind
and i sort of put it i it occurred to me
but i didn't do much about it and then i
met a girl who was the first girl who
paid any kind of serious attention to me
at least i thought it was serious i
lasted a month
and in that month she said you could be
and she was going to drama teacher
college because her parents
traditionally want you to have something
to fall back on
and uh she suggested you could be an
actor she could have said astronaut and
i'd have given that shot too
i completely understand when when did
you feel
like you could just act and pay your
rent when did you feel like you had made
that transition wow that's that you have
to go forward a few years i would think
it was probably
i mean i you know i was an average mess
as a young man
in terms of having anywhere to live i
very rarely had anywhere regular to live
and i did a lot of um you know we used
to live in squats where you'd have to
take they'd bang the boards back up
across the front door every day you'd
have to tear them off to get you know to
get a night's sleep
it was not unusual it was a regular
thing but um
i so therefore but i would think it was
probably where i thought oh now i can
really pay the rent you mean like
forever
like no just like you you know for you
were for like the next six months oh i
have over the next month i have money
for for a flat well i mean i had that
when i
when i took a theater job and you take a
season so yeah i mean i paid the rent i
paid the rent you know when i was 20
probably five or six years where and
then i got you know a season in a
theater at like in liverpool or or on a
tour and i could probably pay the rent
for a while but of course i didn't pay
the rent i spent it in other words
well you mean you were probably in your
20s and that's what you do that's what
you do
i was always a little behind on the rim
jumping into living um i read that this
all sort of started because you met up
with the guys and were having drinks
we were having dinner at stephen woolley
the great english film producer's house
who's a great friend of mine and who
with whom i've made two other films and
uh
in fact i forgot that i was supposed to
be having dinner and i fell asleep on
the sofa and when i when stephen rang me
and said where the
are you and i uh i managed to get in a
cabin and get it because i was only i
only i nearly stood up you know the the
nobel prize winning world famous
novelist is who has always encouraged me
to call him ish but i've never been able
to bring myself to do it anyway we had
dinner and they just sit there they're
film nerds of the highest order they sit
there all night long challenging each
other with uh with the
film facts
and they largely to do with black and
white british films between 1930 and
1960 and they'll say who designed that
and who played the detective at the end
and what are the three parts did he play
and who was played the second lead in
the you know whatever and who was the
cinematographer on that you know they do
that all night then at the end
ishiguro and his wife laura went into a
huddle and they came out of the huddle
and they said we know what your next
film should be and i said well when
you're ready let me know and a couple of
weeks later stephen ramirez said this is
the plan
and it was a terrific plan because
ishiguro was gonna trans was it was well
it was a daunting plan because you're
about to if we could avoid the word
remake i would but we can't reimagine a
famous film by one of the most famous
filmmakers in the history of film
kurosawa and his film ikuru
we were going to reimagine that into
london from tokyo into london in 1953
but the good news was ishiguro was going
to be doing that
so i figured we were in good hands and
then we found oliver mannis because he
made this terrific film called muffy
m-o-f-i-e
and he came on board and things started
to rock
i i think the script for this is just so
well done um i'm curious what was your
reaction reading the script and like at
any point before getting the script are
you like i don't know if i want to re
re-imagine this but then when you read
the script you're like oh i want to
reimagine this
well no i was always kind of i don't
know why but i was well because it was
ishiguro i was confident that we'd be
okay i did actually watch the original
i'd never seen it before and i watched
it
and i knew that it would be very
different because
i'm a very different actor from the man
who played the original and
and i and the plans that were they had
visually were very different um
and uh so i wasn't i wasn't anxious
about it but when i read the script i
was very very happy and i was very
encouraged because it was so beautifully
put together and uh
and uh you know and i and i was just i
just thank my lucky stars was it in the
script that you were going to be singing
and did you get was that like a nervous
thing for you
yeah that's a nervous thing for me
there's that bit there's a couple of
bits on the schedule where you go oh god
really i really have to do that on top
of everything else uh
and singing is not something i mean i
can hold a tune you know but i'm not i'm
not you know i i i you know and once i
get going i'm okay but the the prospect
of it was daunting yeah and the fact
that you then you know halfway through
you have to break down you know but
actually that actually that turns out to
be that turned out to be
uh
not
because it's like when you're at a
funeral and everything is fine and you
can hold it together the whole way
through and then they ask you to sing
you know and then they say everybody's
going to sing hey jude and you get to
the second line and you fall apart
because there's something about the
singing that just unlocks all that and
and and threatens all your restraint and
you start in your and you know and you
you well up and you choke up and it's
and it does you know so it actually
helped me
with the emotional aspect of that
particular scene
i thought that scene was so beautiful in
the movie and your emotion in the scene
really translated through the screen for
me um was that something that you did
like multiple takes on or did you did
you guys sort of discuss beforehand you
know i'm gonna be able to do this once
or twice really good and i'm just
curious because it's so much emotion
well no it's funny you should say that
because i suppose now when you say that
i think yeah why didn't we have that
conversation but we didn't have that
conversation i mean and i did it i don't
know how many times i did it oliver
would tell you but i think it was it
must have been 15 times
wow
oh yeah i mean if not more and there
were you know from various angles and
you know obviously and all of that and
um
yeah we really
shot the hell out of that and uh it was
a you know and it was a it was an
averagely uh tough day you know you know
you knew you'd been to work
i am curiou i am like i said earlier i
am a big fan of your work and i'm always
curious about how actors
prepare for say a big moment so
hypothetically speaking you have a
really big scene on a monday um you know
it's going to take a lot out of you it's
it's a tough scene how do you typically
like to prepare for that moment are you
early on you know breaking that thing
down or is it a week out could you sort
of just how do you like to get ready i
like to get ready
weeks i mean it depends on how long you
get you know but i would be ready weeks
before shooting begins
i would have it annotated i would have
stresses put in there i you know uh
which word i'm going to stress i would
have i would sometimes make if if
there's an if there's an accent in
bulgar a voice involved i might do that
on my phone i might record that on my
phone just to be sure the tone is right
but i will minutely study it and then i
will learn it
backwards and sideways so that i can
eventually arrive at a position where i
can say it like it's never occurred to
me before and i've never spoken it
before that's the gig that's all she
wrote you know
the idea that rehearsal is the enemy of
spontaneity is um
it's not true uh it's uh rehearsal and
is the friend of
so-called spontaneity
um
uh because that is the job the job is to
say it over and over and over and over
again until you can give the impression
you've never said it before so and all
of those things you know and i and i but
that doesn't mean to say that i'm going
to be imprisoned in those intonations or
i'm going to deliberate in a certain way
every single time
not at all it just means i'm i'm ready
and open to any eventuality
what do you think might surprise soon to
be fans of the film living about the
making of the film that's a good another
good question um
they might be surprised to know that my
suit was 70 years old
they might be surprised to know that if
you wear a bowler hat and somebody
dropped a brick on your head you'd be
fine
but you they might be surprised to know
that
people thought smoking cigarettes was
really good for your heart
that's how they sold them
uh
they might be surprised to know
that
uh
i had very few carbs throughout the
shooting
and virtually no sugar
uh
they might be surprised to know that amy
lou woods and i had great difficulty not
laughing a lot of the time through some
of the most tragic scenes
because she's
you know irrepressible and incorrigible
she's
a wonderful person and a terrific
artist and we had a great time and
that's not pr
um i believe i'm going to be out of time
so i just have to ask you i am a big fan
of richard curtis and you guys have
worked together a few times um can you
sort of talk about what you love about
working with him and his writing well i
love his writing because he can do that
really rare thing which is you can
arrange for the whole world to laugh at
the same time which is
you know it's not as much of that around
as as would at first appear to be the
case and also that he has the guts to
deal with sentiment he has the courage a
lot of people lack it including critics
he has the guts to go ahead and and to
operate with a certain degree of
sentimentality and to make films
fearlessly make films about how good
people can be and how remarkable they
can be and not retreat into the easier
thing of making films about how bad
things can get
and that takes guts because you're going
to catch a lot of hell for that this is
a lot of people that equate that you
know a lot of people who are too cool
for school who are going to equate that
and some other thing he's not a
manipulative person he's a believer
and uh as a director he's been always
i've worked with him you know twice now
as a director he's impeccable and and
and and has
and is very you know can really help
which is not the case with all
directions
and he's a sensational human being apart
from that
you know but no he's uh he's a wonderful
man and i'm honored to work
that note i want to say again
congratulations on living thank you so
much for giving me your time i wish you
nothing but the best thank you so much
you